there's a John Deere commercial out
there and I've seen it several times and
I've a bunch of times I've watched it
and I've thought oh that's Nick doing
the voiceover in the John Deere
commercial and I wondered is that you it
is not me it is not you because the guy
doing that voice definitely sounds like
he's trying to do your voice I I had a
high esteem for the John Deere
corporation that they make a quality
tractor and then to discover that they
would use an imposter was quite
heartbreaking heartbreaking well why
don't we do this why don't we when we
play I've known you I've not seen this
you've not seen oh I would love this
it's clear this guy is trying to be Nick
Offerman let's take a look your buddy
run is always full of advice usually bad
some when Ron said you'd never afford a
John Deere tractor you knew better even
got a guy in a Mustang they had first of
all that they mentioned a character Ron
they have a voice it's trying to sound
like yours and then they cut to a guy
who's wearing your mustache
they say that flattery is the highest
form of compliment mm-hmm that's what
they classically say
this voice of yours is popular you could
be getting these jobs
yeah it's become a problem and so to
sort of nip that in the bud I'm
announcing here today that I have
created a new product and if if it's
okay I've brought a commercial with me
I'd love to debut it on your program do
you ever have an uncontrollable urge to
purchase a product or service but suffer
from the nagging feeling that there's
something you don't quite trust then you
might be having a stroke or even worse
you could be watching a TV commercial
done with a nick offerman impressionist
hi
I'm Nick Offerman and no I'm not the
voice from those potato snack or tractor
commercials those men are frauds and
someday they will burn for their crimes
my point is white listen to imitation
knock-offs one you can enjoy the real
thing introducing Nick Offerman's
genuine voice just one dose of Nick
Offerman's genuine voice provides
instant relief and the kind of trust
that can help advertisers sell virtually
any product even the crappy ones from
industrial farm equipment to weird stuff
ladies need for down there Nick
Offerman's genuine voice delivers
positive and long-lasting results Nick
Offerman's genuine voice accept no
substitutes
[Applause]
[Music]